suis très heureux de vous accueillir je
vais redire à l'intention de jean pierre
le goff ce que vous savez c'est à dire
que vous qui êtes là et vous remercions
de votre présence vous n'être que la
partie émergée de l'iceberg puisque
c'est sur internet que nous avons le
plus de spectateurs d'auditeurs de
passionner pour ces conférences du mardi
je suis très heureux que jean pierre le
goff est accepté de venir avec nous
alors c'est un personnage est un esprit
très original non pas parce qu'il est à
la fois philosophe et sociologue en a
heureusement quelques-uns mais parce que
ses centres d'intérêt sont des centres
d'intérêts au croisement de la question
de la société et de la question de la
démocratie
alors je vais faire très vite et en deux
mots
jean pierre le goff a travaillé sur à
partir de son expérience d'étudiant en
68 il a travaillé sur l'ensemble des
questions de
l'évolution de la gauche sur l'ensemble
des questions qui tiennent à la
représentation qu'une société se fait de
son avenir il a travaillé sur
l'entreprise et il a travaillé sur
l'évolution des communautés qui forment
une société à partir de son livre le
plus récent et principal vous en avez
peut-être écrit 1
depuis je ne sais pas qui s'appelle la
fin du village qui traite d'un village
je dirai un mot de ce mot dans une
seconde qui s'appelle cadenet qui est
dans le dans le midi et dans l'eau
travers duquel il analyse la fin d'une
certaine idée de la communauté des
solidarités du destin partagé de
l'enracinement village qu'il a étudié en
y vivent sur 25 ans un quart de siècle
et donc c'est une chose extrêmement
intéressante est extrêmement précieuse
en même temps il a porté une question
qui est celle de
la représentation par les démocraties et
par les citoyens de ce qu'est leur vie
politique leur délibération sur leur
avenir la manière dont ils se le
représente
et vous voyez que ces deux questions
sont évidemment à la fois intimement
liés et crucial s'il le permet je
voudrais que il n'oublie pas de nous
parler peut-être à la fin de la
réflexion qui est la sienne il a écrit
ces jours ci un article très intéressant
sur le mouvement autour du mariage pour
tous en relation avec 68 dans lequel il
voit un symptôme je parle des
manifestations et des résistances ce
mariage pour tous dans lequel il voit un
symptôme d'une réaction profonde d'une
partie de la société en tout cas qui se
sent profondément bouleversé troublé
dans un certain nombre de cadres a
priori comme ready quelqu'un d'autre de
sa sensibilité et de sa vision de
l'homme et du monde
autrement dit il n'y voit pas un
mouvement
uniquement de conservatisme
réactionnaire
il y voit quelque chose d'une attente
plus profonde et il s'inquiète de ce que
au fond la partie de la gauche qui voit
l'héritage de 68 comme l'essentiel de
son message 1,68 continuer si j'ose dire
passe selon lui à côté de quelque chose
de précieux dans la société et entraîne
un mouvement
j'ai trouvé que c'était une analyse très
fine du passage au fond de la question
sociale la question sociétale ou de
l'abandon de la question sociale pour ne
se concentrer que sur la question
sociétale
j'ai trouvé cette analyse tout à fait
pertinentes et vous voyez que c'est une
question là qui paraissent distinctes y
compris la question de l'entreprise
parce que jean pierre le goff a beaucoup
travaillé sur la souffrance au travail
ces questions là sont en fait très
intimement liés et constituent les
éléments de du monde
les éléments principaux du monde que
nous allons vivre voilà pourquoi j'ai
été très heureux que jean pierre le goff
acceptent de venir avec nous ce qui nous
permet aussi de lui dire que pour
beaucoup d'entre nous ces travaux sont
précieux et donc nous avons beaucoup de
gratitude à sa présence c'est jean
pierre rioux qui va maintenant lancer
jean pierre le goff y en a un autre
jeune historien du temps présent donc
trouvé bien oui le texte auquel françois
bellot fait référence dans vous l'avez
dans le monde du 25 mai de samedi
dernier fiasco politique des élites
soixante huitard nk est un un thème très
cher à jean-pierre le goff depuis depuis
de cuisine de très nombreuses années je
vous signale qu'il a redoublé dans le
parisien d'hier n'est ce pas sur la
france coupée en deux vous trouvez une
petite interview en page 2 sur la france
est morcelé et une réponse qu'il va
peut-être lui donner tout à l'heure en
fin de séance à des questions assez
simple pourquoi y at-il tant le monde
dans la rue qui sont ils
ça traduit quoi et est-ce qu'on va vers
une droitisation de la société et
surtout peut-être plus important pour
nous le mouvement de la manif pour tous
doit-il se transformer en courant
politique c'est dans le droit fil de
tout ce que jean pierre le goff fait
depuis de très nombreuses années
françois bayrou signalé je dirais son
passé
en mai 68 ce n'était pas n'importe quel
passé puisque c'était à caen et c'était
dans un milieu qui pour nous qu'ils
réfléchissent en la politique et à la
société a été tout à fait formidable
parce que venus de l'ensemble des
départements normands ont trouvé à la
fois un an un ancien élève de l'école
normale d'instituteurs de saint lô qui
s'appelle marcel gaucher ont trouvé un
ethnologue qui s'appelait alain caillé
ont trouvé un sociologue un peu dans la
veine de jean pierre le goff depuis qui
s'appelait paul yonnet et donc il y
avait là un milieu le tome très marquée
par claude lefort et il y a eu l'âge du
haydn une de ces conjonctions régionales
et provinciales qui ont fait de lever
tant de choses qu'on soit à cancon soit
clermont ferrand qu'en soit à besançon à
lyon et c'est ça qui a fait lever
beaucoup de choses dans la réflexion et
jean pierre le goff a poursuivi sur
cette lancée là n'est ce pas outre je
dirais c'est ces tracts ces travaux
propres sociologue de terrain et
derrière enquêteurs sur la formation le
management le travail la modernisation
bien sûr qu'est ce que c'est que des
jeunes dans le bâtiment et à l'époque il
a beaucoup travaillé c'était à l'époque
quand même assez rare chez les
sociologues qui était très je dire
encore très disposé en école le rival
n'est ce pas entre mon dieu faut-il
choisir crozier paix à son âme n'est ce
pas il y fourre le saluer ce soir bien
sûr comme il faudrait saluer aussi un
peu plus attentivement un formidable
professeur de droit constitutionnel qui
s'appelle guy carcassonne n'est ce pas
qui a tant fait pour nous aider à
comprendre ces fichus institutions de la
vème république bien et donc il a aussi
et c'était assez rare je lui je le
répète chez les sociologues et être
disposé ce que tu es touraine est ce que
tu es bourdieu est ce que tu es crozier
etc
c'était un pataquès pape aussi n'est ce
pas l'époque avec en plus
l'injonction à très haute dose de la
sociologie à l'américaine pour dire vite
et donc là il a été de ceux qui très
vite se sont dit mais nous n'allons pas
continuer à chercher trop de lois la
chute du real de sociologie classique
nous allons nous intéresser aussi et aux
représentations
qu'est ce que les gens ont dans la tête
en se fiant au travail ou en étant à
pied d'oeuvre dans le bâtiment et ça ça
a été pour y compris pour les historiens
temps françois n'est ce pas ça a été
extrêmement important pour tous ceux qui
s'intéressaient aux dimensions
culturelles du du passé et de l'avenir
bien alors ça a donné une première
réflexion sur la démocratie joue signé
en 2002 qui s'appelle et c'est en plein
dans nos sujets la démocratie post
totalitaire n'est pas sans son livre il
nous a vraiment appris beaucoup par son
livre sur mai 68
sous titre l'héritage impossible et là
vous avez déjà pourquoi
il y a eu à la fois échec du gauchisme
politique et triomphe du gauchisme
culturel fac et qu'est ce que c'est que
cette contradiction et ça il a essayé de
il a dit qu'est ce que c'est que la
rupture de génération qui s'annonce dans
tout ça et est-ce qu'on va vers une
société où l'individu autonome et sans
racines et s'enracine deviendra le nec
plus ultra des choses et donc il a été
de ceux qui ont fait vraiment alors que
tant de sociologues et des béland devant
mai 68 n'est ce pas il a été de ceux qui
nous ont appris à critiquer cet héritage
là est posée la question de fond clique
qui travaillent nos générations
pourquoi l'engagement de cette
génération at il échoué quoi finalement
pourquoi on s'est trompé jean pierre le
goff a toujours dit puisqu'on s'est
trompé mettons nous au boulot de manière
encore plus forte et plus et plus
d'intelligente il a fait un autre livre
qui pour nous est importante pas la
gauche à l'épreuve c'est dès 2011 ses
tantes à puce vous voyez où il analyse
vraiment très très fortement je trouve
comment on en arrive à cette espèce de
formidables banalisation au ps et
ailleurs qui est quand même le signe
d'un d'un vide d'ambition inquiets qui
nous interrogent politiquement et
aujourd'hui encore ô combien
qu'est ce que c'est que cette tentation
de sortir de l'histoire dans cette
gauche
exactement et pourquoi et comment
et que c'est que nous le vivons
douloureusement aujourd'hui pourquoi et
comment ce ps va en fait se mettre à
surfer sur les seules évolutions de ce
surtout sur toutes les évolutions de
société et exclusivement c'est
pratiquement exclusivement sur elle et
nous en avons depuis un an que la
démonstration parfaite
et puis leur après on arrive à notre
propos il a donné 1 en 2008 se livre la
france morcelée où il annonce tout ce
qu'il va démontrer
plus précisément encore au fond du
vaucluse avec la fin du village qui est
paru l'an dernier et c'est une réflexion
qui pour nous est extrêmement importante
sur space de france à la fois morcelé
bien sûr mais dans l'ours helmand il ya
plus que ça il y a
ce que moi j'appelle le dépaysement part
eyal cette espèce de perte de 2,2
rapport au pays et à l'espace puisque on
est entré dans des zones des spasmes
mobile dans un stand espace mobile n'est
ce pas et un géographe jacques levy sort
un livre là actuellement chez fayard qui
s'appelle un réinventer la france où il
dit on entre dans un temps d' espaces
mobiles dont les potentialités se situe
à de multiples seychelles alors c'est du
vocabulaire de deux géographes mais on
comprend n'est ce pas et du coup vous
exceptionnellement on comprend surtout
que jacques lévy pour du jeu graphique à
sciences po vous le savez n'est pas des
plus étapes parfois un peu des plusieurs
meetic c'est vrai mais en ajoutant une
cordée venenum n'est ce pas est-ce que
du coup pour être bien bien à l'aise
dans ces espaces mobiles il faut il faut
déconsidérer les
et les mythes nationaux et et le passé
mythifié voilà alors je n'en dis pas
plus et lui donne la parole et jean
pierre le goff sur la france morcelée la
fin de la ville à bord des bus au départ
avant je voulais vous remercier parce
que ça fait des années que j'attends un
peu cette rencontre à vrai dire puisque
je suis quand même tout ce que françois
bayrou écrit depuis le début j'ai été un
est l'auteur du modem pour il faut
cacher et donc je j'attendais un peu une
forme aussi dialogue puisque ils se
trouvent
je ne crois pas me tromper qu'il ya
quand même des points de deux rencontres
qui me semble assez forte
voilà alors j'ai une demi heure pour
vous parler d'un problème compliqué je
vais quand même essayer d'aller à
l'essentiel parce que la question qui
m'a été posée ces fins du village france
morcelée quelles réponses
alors si vous voulez mais la difficulté
c'est délicat à traiter puisque en fait
mon livre on dernier livre n'apporte pas
tellement sur les réponses
ça veut pas dire du tout que je m'en
désintéresse mais dans ce domaine là
j'estime que j'ai beaucoup à apprendre
de deux points de vue c'est à dire du
point de vue de la société elle-même
puisque j'estime qu'en delà du constat
assez critique quand même que je porte
sur l'état de la de la france
aujourd'hui il y a des choses qui se
font ici ou là à l'intérieur même de la
société qui constituent autant de
pratiques qui sont tout à fait novatrice
intéressante
simplement ces pratiques et ces
expériences ne font pas corps ne recrée
pas encore une dynamique une nouvelle
dynamique historique ça ne veut pas dire
qu'elle n'existe pas puis le deuxième
point sur les réponses moi je suis un
citoyen ordinaire et je suis très
curieux mais c'est plutôt un mouvement
politique de meules apporter des
réponses très précises par rapport à ces
défis néanmoins je me déroberai pas
j'indiquerai quelques axes mais très
généraux parce que c'est aux politiques
on a vu des rapports c'est moi je ne
suis pas un politique alors je suis
rapidement si vous voulez je vous
propose de développer mon propos en
trois points d'abord partir de ce que
très rapidement ce qui était l'ancien
collectivités villageoise ce qu'elle est
devenue
les grandes étapes parce que je serais
obligé des testaments schématique qui
ont conduit à sa transformation un
bouleversement pour pouvoir m'arrêter un
peu plus avec vous ce que j'appelle les
fractures quelques grandes fractures que
j'ai pu observer à travers un microcosme
qu'est celui d'un bourg provençal
puisque la villa je reviendrai mais qui
me semble concerner la société française
voilà
et puis je terminerai sur des axes
puisqu'on m'a posée quelles propositions
alors je vais vous donner un peu mais
les ten ma réflexion sur ce point
d'abord peut-être pour bien me faire
comprendre si vous voulez ya deux livres
qui ont déterminé ce travail qui a duré
quand même cinq ans d'écriture des
enquêtes etc
c'est d'abord un livre que je trouve
extraordinaire qui est de laurent
swahili qui est un américain qui a
travaillé sur roussillon lendemain de la
seconde guerre mondiale qui est un livre
d'ailleurs assez peu connue pour moi
c'est un des grands livres au delà même
du village de roussillon donc dans le
lubéron qui est un état de la france y
compris du point de vue anthropologique
je trouve ça très grand document
simplement ce qu'il faut avoir en tête
c'est la france directement au lendemain
de la seconde guerre mondiale dans un
moment historique précis au moment où le
pays n'est pas tout à fait encore entrer
dans la dynamique des trente glorieuses
et à travers ce village c'est la france
quasiment d'avant c'est à dire celle de
la troisième république
un peuple de paysans d'ouvriers
travaillent de locre et c'est bon ça
c'est un livre qui m'a beaucoup frappée
il ya un espèce de dialogue intérieur
parce que la question que je me suis
posée quel est il devenu de cette
collectivité villageoise que décrivait
très bien laurent soit elie qui vivaient
là bas que sa famille et que ses enfants
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que c'est devenu
cette communauté il se trouve que ce
livre je les amenais jeu le j'en ai lu
des extraits avec les anciens villageois
qui trouvais ça formidable puisque
évidemment ça leur rappeler tout à fait
leur passé
le bon temps qui a été fini donc ça
c'est un premier dialogue avec lui
surtout c'est pas trop loin c'est une
vingtaine de kilomètres même si c'est
différent comme bourg puisque c'est du
côté de la durance enfin je peux rentrer
dans le détail le deuxième grand livre
mon avis qui est intéressant qui est un
dialogue s'est évidemment edgar morin
sur klose et net
alors ce qui est intéressant c'est
pourquoi parce que l'on n'est pas la
même époque là on est en plein dans les
trente glorieuses
on est vraiment bon des années 60
est ce que note à ce moment-là tango
talent oui pendant bretagne parce que
pour moi c'est évident mais et donc ils
notent espère albert et audierne voilà
je savais pas et il ya une dynamique ce
qui ce qui est très frappant quand vous
lisez
bon c'est la dynamique historique sert
l'optimisme d'ailleurs avec une certaine
dépréciation du passé mais là on est en
plein et là on voit une transformation
de l'agriculture
un optimisme des paysans d'ailleurs
qu'ils étaient menés par les syndicats
chrétiens qui ont joué un rôle
absolument essentiel dans la
transformation de l'agriculture donc on
est vraiment véritablement porté par un
optimisme du progrès donc ces deux
livres
la question est très simple qu'en est il
aujourd'hui c'est à dire si je me
resituer première étape à la deuxième
étape il parlait pas de troisième étape
mais quid du village à l'heure de la
crise j'allais dire voilà donc si vous
voulez la la démarche
je vais donner un deuxième exemple pour
bien me faire comprendre c'est les
affiches de françois mitterrand à fils
de 1965 où la fiche un peu jaune
d'ailleurs j'ai autant je m'en souvienne
et vous avez françois mitterrand un
président jeune pour une france moderne
je crois que c'est ça et vous avez
c'était plus grise était plus grosse que
est en fait vous avez un espèce de
poteaux électriques en fait une ligne à
haute tension est derrière vous avez une
usine au bout d'un champ bon on est en
1965 ce qui est tout à fait intéressant
c'est de comparer cette image à 1980
la force tranquille qu'est ce qu'on voit
retour sur le village c'est quand même
extraordinaire là qu'est ce qui s'est
passé entre les deux il s'est passé deux
grands événements mon avis tu aurais fin
deux événements historiques considérable
d'abord d'une certaine façon mai 68 et
porte est passée par là mai 68 dans une
de ses mines mention enfin c'est
l'analyse que j'en fais c'est
l'interrogation de la société sur elle
même par rapport aux bouleversements
considérables qu'elle a traversée depuis
la seconde guerre mondiale tire toute la
modernisation de l'après-guerre a
bouleversé considérablement le pays et
il ya ce que j'appelle donc pas duré
très longtemps un moment de pause et de
catharsis voyons sommes-nous heureux la
modernisation oui mais pour quoi faire
et pour aller où
il me semble que tu sais pas l'ensemble
de l'événement de mai 68 mais cette
question était présente dans l'événement
donc premièrement ce que d'ailleurs
raymond aron a appelé immédiatement se
sentent 9 un livre de lui qui est peu
connu mais qui me semble très
intéressant qui s'appelle les
désillusions du progrès ça c'est le
premier événement qui pour expliquer
cette c'est ce changement le deuxième
événement il vient tout de suite dans la
foulée c'est à dire 73-74 tiers crise du
pétrole fin fin de la dynamique des
trente glorieuses montée des thèmes
écologie donc je crois que je vous
aiderai se dresse un portait isa joue
les rapides de la france mais c'est un
peu l'arrière fond de monde de mes
interrogations sur le village
à vrai dire la question est très simple
je me suis posé bon qu'en est il advenu
de cette collectivité aujourd'hui à
travers cette collectivité
qu'en est il advenu de l'ancien peuple
de france papa ancien peuple de france
on peut discuter un peu je dirais je me
réfère un peu à péguy c'est à dire ce
peuple aussi j'ai 10 rebonds pour le cas
concret de deux paysans de vanier mais
j'ai connu puisque j'ai quand même dans
ma courte biographie j'ai voyagé un peu
dans différentes régions j'ai connu les
jeux d'hier les marins pêcheurs puisque
je suis d'une famille de marins pêcheurs
j'ai connu les mines les mineurs du nord
et aussi les les provençaux donc j'ai
connu un peu cet ancien humus on va dire
emma la question qui me préoccupe
d'ailleurs depuis un moment c'est qu'est
ce qu'il est devenu
qu'est-ce qui est devenu voilà un peu
les questions alors je vais très vite un
puisque j'ai j'ai maintenant vingt
minutes
rapidement l'ancien collectivités
prononça les particularités de cannes et
je pas rentrer trop dans le détail c'est
un vieux village ancestral avec son
château du moyen-âge etc
c'est un bourg plus qu'un village il
c'est un gros bourg et c'est un chef
lieu de canton et c'est pour ça qu'il
faut pas avoir en tête les images du
village du luberon qui sont fermés
l'hiver là c'est un village qui restent
actifs s'ils voulaient qu est composé
d'actifs enfin c'est un peu particulier
je vous expliquais tout à l'heure mais
surtout ce qui m'a intéressé c'est que
quand vous allez là bas les gens parlent
du village par du village alors que
c'est plus le village
c'est une question d'ailleurs bon on va
arriver au mois de juillet vous allez
voir tous les hebdomadaires les villages
et se trouve que c'est mon interrogation
aussi la france est complètement
urbanisées elle s'est transformée et
pour autant il y a les restes d'un
imaginaire extrêmement fort extrêmement
puissants du village alors la question
c'est pourquoi pourquoi alors que la
réalité est à mon avis la france est
devenue urbaine est alors pour pour
cannes et c'est d'autant plus fort je me
suis posé la question pourquoi ça bout
cet amour typique troisième république
je parle pas du bar des bulls j'ai passé
beaucoup de temps jeu de boules sur les
platanes le monument son monument du
tambour d'arcole enfin vous avez un
espèce d'archétypes extraordinaire de ce
qu'a pu être le village sous la
troisième république parce que le temps
pour d'arcole était supposé être de la
voix la supposée alors oui il ya la
plaque dans la petite rue et cetera je
ne sais pas j'ai pas vérifié les
catégories sociales rapidement paysans
et vanier essentiellement et c'est ce
qu'on appelle ancien village
c'est vraiment une collectivité
extrêmement soudée j'y rajoute une
caractéristique rapide c'est un village
rouges considéraient comme rouge toute
la question de savoir qu'est ce que
c'est devenu tout ça j'insisterai sur
des caractéristiques qui débordent
cannes et quand on parlait de village à
l'époque ça voulait dire qu'il y avait
la concentration dans un même espace
géographique de l'habitation du travail
de ce qu'on appelle les loisirs en
sachant que les loisirs à l'époque était
hilare étroitement articulé au travail
ce n'est plus le cas aujourd'hui ça
c'est une première caractéristique le
deuxième caractéristique c'est des
relations interpersonnelles de
solidarité ce que j'appellerais un ordre
de proximité ça veut dire que tout le
monde connaît tout le monde
tout le monde est issu de la famille
enfin parce que j'appelais gens d'ici et
on repère les gens par la filiation ce
qu'il va devenir peut-être un peu plus
compliqué mais bon donc et un ordre de
proximité tout le monde connaissant tout
le monde
quand vous faites vous pouvez pas faire
de grosses bêtises pour les enfants
puisque les parents connaissaient
parents des enfants donc et ça se
réguler une eau parlons en jargon
autorégulation autorégulation mais
c'était comme ça avec troisième
caractéristique extrêmement important
l'attachement affectif l'investissement
affective à ce qu'on appelait la petite
patrie et cette petite patrie était un
univers familier camp parce que j'ai
interrogé les anciens c'est un
attachement d'autant plus fort que ça ne
correspond plus c'est à à tel point par
exemple j'ai un ancien du village qui
avait fait son service militaire à
avignon il avait quitté le village ils
étaient complètement perdus où j'ai
encore cette dame
qui vend des kaka il rit client monsieur
ma fille voulu fait de quitter le
village et le pleure vous avez des
chiffres assez extraordinaire vous
apercevez qu'il ya un attachement
c'est vrai quand vous vivez à paris ou
ailleurs vous dit c'est pas possible et
pourtant il est là alors cette petite
patrie et c'est très important ce sans
boiter d'une certaine façon dans la
grande part deux institutions l'école
par l'histoire de france par la
géographie rossi tant le lieu dans un
plus grand espace et par l'histoire de
france voilà et je dirai quand je parle
de l'attachement il ya un mot allemand
ca himat le chez soi si vous voulez
c'est à dire le premier lieu originaire
qui donne familiarité sens au monde si
je prends des catégories de l'anah à
rennes et qui rend le monde humain et
vous apercevez que c'est quand je parle
du village c'est plus qu'un espace
géographique c'est plus qu'un bâti c'est
un univers un monde il ya je ne sais pas
si vous avez connu ce feuilleton il ya
quelques années que ça plaît à immat qui
était l'évolution en allemagne et vous
voyez très bien ce que ça veut dire
quand le soldat rentrer de la guerre de
1914 et traverse le village et retrouve
le imac le chez soi
voilà alors dernier élément c'était je
voulais dit une pauvreté ce traitement
dans le sang ce jeu là j'ai pas joué la
nostalgie mais enfin les le confort et
l'hygiène était plus que relatif c'était
des conditions d'habitat des conditions
de travail tellement dur et je dirais
aussi un poids de la collectivité sur
l'individu extrêmement forts notamment
avec ce phénomène des commérages
il se trouve que je
interrogeant un ancien je lui dis mais
c'était terrible et commérages idiot
hystérie mais au moins pour se défendre
publiquement sur la place tandis que
seat est lynché par les médias c'est
fini j'ai trouvé ce n'était pas
totalement faux si voulez vous êtes
impact a plus de possibilité de te
défendre quoi alors
l'évolution globale séoul et ben quand
vous regardez j'ai très vite par rapport
à ce premier modèle vous apercevez qui a
éclatement et ça c'est central lieu
d'habitation
le travail de loisirs avec un mobilité
qui va avec
vous avez également l'étalement du
village par la construction de
lotissements qui se sont développées de
façon considérable et vous avez un
phénomène s'cusez moi l'expression mais
dans le sud on parle beaucoup de bronze
cul de l'europe concernant la provence
où des millions de personnes arrivent à
partir du mois de juin il faut il faut
voir la déferlante sur vire je suis allé
moi au mois de juillet à saper la
roussillon le lensois et lee c'était au
mois de juillet j'y suis rentré à 10h je
suis parti à 10h30 parce que c'est le
mont saint michel en pire si vous voulez
bon alors les catégories sociales c'est
ça qui est intéressant je vais parler
d'un peuple de paysans et de vanier
par quoi il était remplacé accès notable
dentiste enfin voyez le notaire le
médecin et cetera le curé l'instituteur
et bien vous avez aujourd'hui dans cet
éclatement un pôle ce qu'on pourra
appeler les très très riches
c'est très récent je reviendrai sur les
différentes étapes des on pourra lire
des élites un peu mondialisée des hauts
cadres des grandes entreprises ministre
multinationales ou des fonctionnaires
internationaux qui vont trouver dans la
provence
une espèce d'enracinement qu'ils ont
perdue d'une certaine façon
et comme j'ai interrogé aussi évidemment
les agences immobilières ce sont
d'excellents clients parce qu'ils ne
posent aucun problème s'ils recherchent
toujours les caves voûtées comme s'ils
d'authenticité
et puis il rachète si vous voulez les
les belles maisons d'ailleurs entre
parenthèses autrement il serait tombé en
ruine faut jamais l'oublier non plus
mais j'ai vu tout à fait l'évolution
entre un paysan que j'ai bien connue qui
a vendu sa propriété qu'elle était
racheté d'abord par un dentiste qui
venaient du nord de la france qui a
ensuite a été racheté par un haut cadre
anglais qui partait le matin prenez
l'avion revenait et caetera et qui
maintenant et a été de nouveau racheté
par des grandes fortunes où a lieu des
manifestations assez particulière bon je
suis pas les détails et tous les ans
dans la colline avec des bruits très
assourdissant enfin voilà donc vous avez
une évolution comme ça alors un qu'un
pôle les très très riches et à l'autre
pôle ce que j'ai appelé de ses passes
pas jugement moral la déglingue
qu'est ce que je veux dire par là des
lags la déglingue ces deux nouvelles
formes de pauvreté qui ne se confondent
pas avec celles du passé je m'explique
en deux mots quand vous vous regardez
les mémoires des vanniers par exemple
est beaucoup d'interviews d'anciens
vanier qui était fait vous apercevez que
c'était des gens extrêmement pauvres qui
travaillaient dans des conditions très
difficiles
vin très difficile pour nous aujourd'hui
c'est à dire dans des calmes souvent
éclairé à la bougie ou les enfants
commencé très tôt ou des ateliers où
vous étiez dans des conditions d'hygiène
et de travail difficiles et gagner
quelques sous qui était souvent dépensé
dans l'est dans les différents bars il y
en avait beaucoup à l'époque lors qu'ils
aient pu beaucoup bon voilà donc vous
aviez ces conditions là et pourtant il
ya quelque chose qui je les dires
transcender ces conditions de cette
dureté de la vie
d'abord tout le monde était pauvre et
tout le monde avait une grande
solidarité à tel point exemple
allez-vous langeree avait plusieurs
pôles de boulangerie plusieurs
boulangeries dans le village et bien on
s'arrange et le lundi le jour du marché
pour ne pas défavoriser telle
boulangerie par rapport à l'autre voyez
c'était un sentiment d'égalité
extrêmement extrêmement fort et de
solidarité que bon
peut-être moi j'ai connu ça aussi en
normandie où j'ai vécu bon yaya le deuil
de la kangoo z'avez un deuil à deux
voisins qui et à quoi donc d'aider
grande grande solidarité si vous voulez
donc alors ça ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que les conditions de travail la
pauvreté était d'une certaine façon
transcendé par les rapports pas parler
jargonner les rapports sociaux mais les
rapports de solidarité de fraternité qui
existent et à l'intérieur même de la
collectivité
c'est ça et il faut bien l'avouer est et
comment dire une certaine estime de soi
une fierté
vous pouviez prouve mais vous étiez fier
ça c'est bon je peux reprendre peggy
mais c'est exactement ce qu'il raconte
comment le monde moderne et d'une
certaine façon à bousculer tout ça mais
c'était quand vous dire quand vous
regardez mémoire des vanniers c'était ça
aujourd'hui c'est à quoi ton affaire on
a affaire à la situation tout à fait
inédite à mon sens on retrouve
évidemment des aspects de la misère
anciennes notamment ceux qu'on pas de
travail je pourrais parler des logements
sociaux de la politique des logements
sociaux etc mais ils n'ont pas de
travail mais ce manque de travail c'est
ap ce chômage avec ce qu'il implique
parce que pour moi le chômage n'est pas
simplement une dimension économico
sociale c'est éminemment une dimension
anthropologique dans la mesure où
l'individu à partir du moment où il
travaille est confronté à l'épreuve du
réel rentrer dans des rapports avec les
autres qui sur la foi des rapports de
coopération et de conflit et donc d'une
certaine égale sa vie et gagner sa vie
pour reprendre une vieille expression
c'est quelque chose essentielle de
l'estimé de soi c'est précisément cet
élément-là qui manque les vanniers était
paumé il travaillait et il avait cette
dimension de solidarité à cette
dimension du chômage sont ajoute une
autre qui pour moi est essentiellement
qu'on a beaucoup de mal à bord des quais
l'éclatement des familles je suis
absolument frappé à canet par cet
éclatement
ce qui fait que vous avez des gens sans
travail ou des jeunes qui vit
fraction minoritaire dans le village
mais c'est quand même intéressant dans
des espèces de fratries complètement des
affiliés c'est que vous voyez traîner
dans les rues le soir et qui sont en
situation d'errance
bon ce qui pose d'ailleurs un certain
nombre de problèmes la coexistence de
ces familles je pourrais vous le
détailler mais j'ai pas le temps avec
les autres catégories de la population
parce que ça ne va pas de soi et les
tensions montent ils auraient donc vous
avez ces catégories nouvelles entre les
deux vous avez quoi vous avez des
couches moyennes qui sont arrivés à
cannes né dans les années 1980 qui
venait d'aix-marseille qui ont acheté
des logements qu'ils pouvaient faire des
prêts sauf qu'aujourd'hui c'est fini
c'est fini pourquoi parce que il y à une
flambée des prix énormes sur les
terrains et ses couches moyennes sont
terriblement inquiète parce que leurs
enfants ne pourront plus habiter sur
place
d'ailleurs ils vont dans les
hautes-alpes des ménages dans les
hautes-alpes c'est à dire c'est qu'ils
étaient possibles encore dans les années
80 avec l'arrivée du tgv est notamment
il ya aussi le projet iter qui fait
peser le problème de foncier qui est
énorme
donc si vous laissez plus possible pour
ces catégories là donc vous avez les
très très riches qu'ils sentent qu'ils
restent minoritaires mais qui arrive de
plus en plus qui rachètent des vies de
mettre des gérants qu'on voit jamais de
l'autre côté vous avez ce que j'appelle
les catégories de précarité entre les
deux vous avez ces couches qui vivent
voilà alors c'est ce que j'appelle le
village bariolés qu'est ce que je veux
dire
ça veut dire qu'à l'intérieur d'un même
espace géographique coexistent des
catégories sociales revenu fort inégaux
mais ce n'est pas là aussi qu'une
question économique et social c'est à la
fois une question économique et social
et c'est une question culturelle dans le
sens où coexistent à l'intérieur ce lieu
géographique des gens aux mentalités
j'allais dire à ces différentes et
parfois contradictoires je reviendrai
sur les fractures mais sa co existent
plutôt pacifiquement d'ailleurs beaucoup
se demandent comment ça n'a pas
encore péter si j'ose dire comment ça
n'est pas passé à des actes eh bien ça
coexistent pacifiquement l'intérieur ce
même espace
mais quand vous regardez l'ancien a même
espace sans culture comme une ancienne
parce qu'il y avait ce vieux fond
d'appartenance sentiment d'appartenance
comme il existait autrefois et surtout
je reviendrai là dessus sans avenir
commun ce qui me paraît absolument
essentiel donc ça coexiste avec des
réseaux qui déborde évidemment le
village monte sur la france avec
internet et c'est avec la mobilité qui
existent donc on est passé de sas alors
comment on en est arrivé là je peux pas
trop détaillé je vais peut-être passer
parce que sinon pourra pas discuter sur
les différentes étapes je dirai
simplement une chose les anciens vous
dit c'est la faute aux gens de la ville
qui sera arrivé parce que maintenant ces
anciens sont minoritaires minoritaires
en fait c'est beaucoup plus compliqué il
ya trois grandes étapes ci roulait pour
faire bref il ya cette question des
trente glorieuses où la société de
consommation la société des loisirs la
télévision l'automobile a cassé d'emblée
à changer la collectivité villageoise et
dans un sens qui n'est pas simplement
négatif
ceux-ci l'ouverture c'est la fin
d'esprit proche de clocher mais en même
temps ce qu on ya gagné en bien-être
matériel on a perdu en lien de
solidarité
bon et puis vous avez un deuxième maman
beaucoup plus problématiques qui sont
les années 70 où si rien n'est fait il
ya plus de jeunes
il n'y a plus rien dans le village donc
le maire lance une politique de grands
travaux pour attirer les coaches issus
de la ville d'ailleurs ça va marcher les
gens vont venir habiter kahn n'ait
travaillé avec son marseille maintenant
ils sont obligés de calculer le parcours
comme à paris nos départs ce n'est pas
ça et donc ça finalement c'est pour ça
que canet est demeuré un bourg composé
d'actifs sauf que pour les anciens c'est
un village dortoir
village dortoir pourquoi parce qu'ils
partent à 7h30 quand je 17h30 c'est
cette heure pour aller à marseille
déposé enfants à la crèche j'ai des amis
n'est ce qu'on faisait avec les enfants
la crèche et les reprennent à 6 heures
le soir on les voit jamais dans le
village donc village dortoir c'est
d'expression qu'ils emploient j'en
connais d'autres villages dortoirs je
trouve qu'ils exagèrent à un peu parce
que il y en a d'autres
enfin c'est comme ça alors voilà alors
rapidement je viens aux fractures ceci
ce que peut-être là-dessus que je
devrais je pas tout tous les sites et
j'en ai repéré un certain nombre si vous
voulez je vais aller très vite
ja il ya des fractures qui sont je
voulais dit social mais pas simplement
il ya des fractures culturelles qui sont
transversales aux catégories sociales je
vais en prendre un certain nombre un
nouveau type d'individualistes
problématique jurés me arrêté il ya un
problème que j'aurais pas le temps de
traiter qui me semble essentielle la
question de la famille et la question de
l'éducation des enfants c'est un point
de fracture très important le troisième
point si vous voulez je devais parler la
pauvreté la déglingue mais ce qui
m'intéresse aussi c'est comment sur fond
de chômage de masse et ça pour moi c'est
la question essentielle qu'est ce qu'on
fait il n'y a pas de travail mais il ya
beaucoup d'animations animations
festives animations culturelles sur la
base du chômage de masse et ça je vais
m'y arrêter je prendre rapidement
rapport nous nouvelle forme
d'individualisme et ce qu'ils appellent
les anciens et dix maisons tous la manie
de la clôture la manie de la clôture
c'est parce que quand ils arrivent ils
se barricadent alors y'a l'issue
annoncée à 4 as
les suisses arrivent vous les voyez dans
la campagne à des murs ou comme ça
coince quelque oui voilà alors on se
barricade chez soi ça c'est un mode de
vie par rapport à l'ancienne
collectivités on allait au bar par
exemple c'est un critère il veut pas ça
fred s'intégrer il vient pas au bar et
donc on se barricade chez soi s'il est
bon vous avez alors avec des conflits
entre ce qu'ils appellent ce que j'ai
appelé monsieur qui les appelle comme ça
les écologistes d
l'écologiste deschamps je ne peux pas
m'empêcher de vous citer à propose que
ce qui provoque des contradictions je
vous parle pas de la chasse la chasse
est un point de fractures extrêmement
important qui renvoie un rapport à la
nature au fait de tuer des animaux en
sachant qu'on est dans un parc naturel
régional et j'ai également examinées de
près le contenu de l'éducation donnée
aux enfants je dois dire que c'est
vraiment un changement de monde par
rapport à l'ancien et ça passe pas comme
une lettre à la poste si je dis j'ai
simplement vous citez un ancien alors
les écologistes pour eux les écologistes
des villes évidemment ils se promènent à
pied non vtt estime qu'il est naturel
qui traverse la propriété
il profite de la nature des paysans par
contre toi tu ne risques pas d'entrer
chez eux tu ne traverse pas le jardin
écolo surtout si tu chasses
effectivement c'est un peu la même
histoire qui rajoute que pour les
communistes autrefois on partage tout
sur tout ce qui est pas un mois alors
bon vous avez 7 cc conflit extrêmement
dur mais ça renvoie aussi au rapport aux
institutions
c'est à dire les gendarmes un changement
total les gendarmes ont peu flux j'ai
interrogé évidemment tôt les gendarmes
les anciens les nouveaux
j'ai comparé la mentalité des anciens
gendarmes avec les nouveaux jeand'heur
ils n'en peuvent plus parce qu'on les
appelle tous les soirs pour des conflits
de voisinage dit alors ils téléphonent
ssma écoutez vous couriez pas les oies
le voisin elles disent non mais alors il
faut voir aussi que si vous allez voir
le voisin et faut être quand même assez
courageux avec avec un phénomène tout à
fait nouveau c'est que les gens ne se
connaissent plus donc vous ne connaissez
pas le voisin allaient trouver le voisin
vous faites un acte elle connaître alors
qu'avant et légendes et autres choses
que j'ai en interviewant les gendarmes
qui notamment des jeunes gendarmes qui
ne s'attendait pas à ça le temps passe
et pas simplement par la paperasse
mais par la question des divorces et de
l'éclatement des familles allocations
non payées aller chercher sortir
l'enfant du père qui veut taper vous
n'est qu'un relais j'ai étudié la
provence pendant deux ans les faits
divers
vous apercevez quand vous regardez un
peu il ya toujours deux phénomènes
chômage éclatement de la famille qui
passe il part avec des passages à l'acte
et inimaginables sur fond de voisins là
j'ai des tas d'exemples où il est à côté
de chez vous vous le connaissez plus bon
voilà alors le rapport aux institutions
et problématique alors les pompiers
c'est pareil bon je ne résiste pas une
petite citation
aujourd'hui c'est le lieutenant des
pompiers qui est un gars ordinaire
d'ailleurs les gens sont des plus en
plus assister on leur doit tout il ya
une fuite à la machine à laver parce
qu'un tuyau cassé il appelle les
pompiers avant d'aller fermer le robinet
s'il y a un orage avec quelques
centimètres d'eau dans laquelle ils
appellent les pompiers lors des
inondations importantes il fallait
presque être là avant que l'eau soit en
très bon face à ces la provence mais il
a des droits
par exemple lors de vanves à un truc
incroyable et ce que vous voyez pas de
remplir la piscine
alors voilà donc ccc ccc conflit la
déglingue j'en ai parlé je vous parlais
de la déglingue ce phénomène là je
pourrais vous parler longuement de la
politique des logements sociaux qui
produit des fractures cas des effets non
maîtrisée et qui accentue les fractures
je pars le temps ce serait trop long
mais c'est assez intéressant bon je vais
prendre la question de l'animation
culturelle et festive
c'est à dire vous avez d'un côté ses
anciens ces gens qui sont perdus et à
côté vous avez une suractivité de fêtes
diverses et variées d'animation avec la
soeur de feu animateurs de marionnettes
artistes divers
qui expose alors moi et évidemment à
chaque fois j'ai fait des coups de
conférences dans les villages je suis
retourné je retourne la semaine
prochaine pour faire attention je n'ai
rien je le dis tout de suite contre
l'animation socioculturelle je trouve
que là où y'a rien vaut mieux que
quelque chose est bon mais il faut
jamais oublier que ça ne peut pas
remplacer le travail
c'est ça la limite de l'animation or il
se trouve que dans ces villes dans ces
villages dans ces bourgs ya pas de
travail mais il ya beaucoup d'animateurs
je parlerai de la région je parle pas de
la région paca qui dispose d'un le
beaucoup d'associations d'animations
diverses et variées avec ce que ça
représente aussi comme clientèle
électorale rsa c'est un autre sujet en
tout cas ce contraste est frappant
vous avez à partir du mois là ça
commence à un nombre d'événements entre
guillemets et de fait considérable je
vais pas vous les recenser mais c'est
quand même un seul absolument
extraordinaire la fête du cheval la fête
des foins la fête des charrettes avait
quelque chose qui est très étonnant
comme patchwork c'est à dire à la fois
des dimensions très moderne
après tout pourquoi pas de la musique
rock mélangé à des danses gabonaise
et puis le tout mélangé la fête des
foins avec le patrimoine enfin cesser
chose tout à fait bizarroïde de
patchwork un peu aujourd'hui qui reflète
aussi quelque chose de la situation dans
lequel on est alors je ne peux pas
détaillé sur la culture j'aurai beaucoup
de choses à dire
la culture est instrumentalisée dans une
logique d'animation quand on parle de
culture il faut savoir de quoi on parle
on parle essentiellement d'animation
socioculturelle la multiplication des
événements et des fêtes
mais bon je n'ai rien contre mais ça ne
suffit pas et d'autre part comme on dit
la culture c'est très importante parce
que ça crée du lien social je suis
d'accord m'enfin crée du lien social
si ses jours est quand même mieux
commencer par le travail si vous voulez
bon alors voilà
alors rapidement et je terminerai par un
point qui me semble essentiel je dirais
même et mes conclusions ce que j'appelle
un défi considérable à mes yeux les
nouvelles formes de spiritualité diffuse
caisse commandes
je me suis aperçu parce que j'ai
interrogé les curés des anciens des
nouveaux j'interrogeais des bouddhistes
j'ai interrogé des thérapeutes
je résumerai cette nouvelle spiritualité
en quelques mots si je dis bien diffuse
n'y a pas de dogme être bien dans sa
tête et dans son corps dans un rapport
réconcilie à soi même à la nature et
avec les autres s'y greffent de
multiples outils de développement
personnel à base de spiritualité
exotiques les plus diverses qui vont du
chamanisme en passant par un bouddhisme
rigidité je dis tout de suite que je
n'ai rien contre le bouddhisme comme
religion mais ce qui est très frappant
c'est des prix comme une religion
ah oui et surtout ce n'est pas une
religion vous avez tout à fait raison ce
que je veux dire par là c'est que c'est
du bricolage
c'est du bricolage individuel à volonté
et dans la région avec le soleil et
cetera le lit parce que c'est du
bouddhisme ce qui m'a frappé j'interroge
une habitant de kato et bouddhiste à la
fois qui dit qu' aucune contradiction il
ya pas de problème etc et qui en fait on
vous creusez bon il ya tous ces cas
fréquenté beaucoup d'analystes de
psychologues et le bouddhisme a une
vertu essentielle ment qui est très
présente et comme thérapeutique
voyez par rapport à une forme de
narcissisme individualisme malheureux
une espèce de réponse qui est qui
souvent mais pour moi c'est pas
forcément le bouddhisme c'est ce qu'un
peu le rapport je suis très frappé d'une
espèce de déculturation les vieilles
fontaine du village choc tran quelques
exemples parmi ce que j'appelle excusez
moi l'expression les cultureux j'ai
beaucoup de respect pour la culture mais
les cultureux retraduit c'est vieille
fontaine en langage zen extrêmement
bizarroïde je prends
l'exemple d'une visite que j'ai fait sur
une artiste qui m'en veut d'ailleurs
beaucoup
le mandala à tout faire vous avez des
mandalas mais alors des mandalas
exotiques mélangeant l'afrique avec la
citation du dalaï lama mélangé à sorte
enfin des des choses tout à fait
étonnante que vous voyez fleurir un peu
partout donc et tout ça c'est ce grand
mélange si vous voulez dans un village
encore une fois qui est situé quai très
touristique
alors pour terminer vous allez en mon
propos est pessimiste
oui peut-être enfin pour moi je vous
suis toujours gramsci c'est facile
pessimiste de l'intelligence optimise de
la volonté puis après tout
l'intelligence a pas être pessimiste
optimiste un bon mais je crois pour
résumer et là je te la danse et je pense
qu'on vit une période très particulière
à mon avis non pas de décadence urpo
poster mes critiques il y en a eu
d'autres
comment l'adn le comment la la
caractérise et je la carrure est la
façon suivante ça n'en finit pas de
finir sans qu'on passe véritablement une
nouvelle dynamique historique c'est à
dire on a on n'en finit pas de voir se
décomposer l'ancien monde sans qu'on
parvienne à retrouver une dynamique
historique qui a existé pendant tout un
moment il se passer et c'est ce que
j'appelle une période critique
encore une fois ça ne veut pas dire
qu'il n'ya pas des choses intéressantes
et des pratiques et des expériences qui
est dans la société semaine mais ces
expériences ne se connaissent pas on
n'arrive pas à en faire un mouvement si
vous le dire alors dans ces conditions
là je crois qu'il faut bien prendre en
compte la dimension d'un nostalgie moi
je les ai vus à canet mais je pense
qu'elle est beaucoup plus large
- vous avez d'avenir plus vous avez
tendance à vous replier sur un passé
d'ailleurs où vous gommer les aspects un
peu contraignant ce qui est assez humain
est logique
est ce qu'une fois beaucoup c'est que la
france enfin une partie de la france
mais les gens
ils sont fatigués n'ont pas de la
modernité ça je ne crois pas du tout
mais du modernisme que je définirais
comme une fuite en avant perpétuelle
sans but ni sens
excusez moi le changement c'est
maintenant je suis d'accord mais c'est
pour quoi faire
yes we can mais we can wait
et si vous voulez ou le présent où le
mot changement par rapport précisément à
la dynamique même historique de progrès
à remplacer ce mot est pour moi c'est
tout à fait significative d'un présent
que j'appellerais un peu
existentiellement flottant je m'explique
quand le passé ne fait plus sens où il
est vu simplement dans la catégorie des
ringards 1 et que caen l'avenir devient
indiscernable ouvert sur de possibles
régressions comment le présent bah il
flotte et comment on le remplit par un
activisme communicationnel et
managériale qui concerne y compris les
individus je suis absolument sûr pays il
ya 40 ans quand vous demandez à
quelqu'un on a rendez vous pouviez même
même au village vous alliez directement
chez lui c'est pas possible on peut
téléphoner à temps là je suis pressée de
multiples activités dire vous vous
demandez comment les gens faisait avant
pour les jeunes il y est c'était
possible c'est l ennui alors qu'il
s'ennuyait pas du tout mais bon donc il
ya cette espèce d'activis managériale et
communicationnel et je dirais que la
politique je permets est concerné
directement par ça
c'est à dire qu'on excusez moi dans les
boîtes à outils et je n'ai rien contre
boîte à outils le problème c'est quelle
boîte à outils pour gérer la complexité
mais encore faut-il savoir où l'on va
comment re citons aussi tu te sens et
boîte à outils ou ses réformes à
l'intérieur d'une vision historique et
là excusez moi je pense que le pays
enfin c'est mon sentiment est en attente
il a envie de passer à autre chose ça
j'en suis absolument persuadé mais qu'
il attend et on n'arrive pas à réans
brayer voilà un peu alors axe vous
m'avez dit avec moi je suis pas un
politique mais je pourrais pas
m'empêcher de dire deux choses
j'avais ça une reconstruction parce que
je pense que on est vraiment il faut
aborder on est en une société qui se
paie de mots la logomachie managériale
et communicationnel sait on a du mal à
aborder la réalité en face
elle sert à mettre à distance le réel et
l'épreuve du réel pourquoi parce que si
on l'a dans la figure
eh bien on est un
peu décontenancé on n'arrête pas de me
dire je suis pessimiste mais non je suis
pas pessimiste il faut quand même
aborder ces phénomènes de front on veut
pas rester en disant mais non c'est pas
grave etc
non je pense que l'état de la france à
la france et est mort se laisser voler
on devine une crise extrêmement grave
enfin c'est mon sentiment alors les
actes de reconstruction possible moi je
vais me situer syrie damas ma petite
place simplement d'abord question numéro
un numéro un le travail avec ce que je
vous ai dit sur la dimension
anthropologique reconstruire les tos de
la société
l'ethos en termes de valeur des
représentations collectives de dynamique
de sentiments positifs passent par
remettre des catégories entières de la
population qui sont au travail et dans
ce coin là je soulignerai juste un point
je suis bien évidemment pour le
développement de la formation
professionnelle je suis bien évidemment
pour le développement de la
compétitivité pour le jouer sur la
qualité par rapport mais il reste un
problème je vais partir deux catégories
les catégories entières de la population
sont désocialisées
on les remettra pas au travail ont les
reprendra pas il se trouve que j'ai
travaillé dans les banlieues et les
jeunes se 6 8 ans avec la l'utopie de
l'époque je me souviens c'était que si
on leur parle et concret alors moi
j'allais acheter pour donner un exemple
tu es en seine-saint-denis un livre qui
parlait des motos alors on faisait leur
taux graf et qu'il moto aux femmes parce
que ça a l'air motivé parce que tu
trahis mais non il était complètement
paumé et et quand vous discutez avec eux
vous aperçu c'était pas le travail on
voulait leur faire passer des ces apps
et s'était même en amont du crp
parce qu'il était complètement d affilée
à chaque fois vous trouviez les mêmes
problèmes
le pape et en valais
les gamins comme ça donc vous avez des
catégories entières qui sont exclues
premier premier problème
deuxième problème les bas niveaux de
qualification est ce que parce que je
suis d'accord sur la compétitivité mais
est ce qu'on peut proposer comme modèle
ce n'est pas possible à une société de
tout le monde doit être ingénieur cadre
si vous n'êtes pas ça vous n'êtes rien
ça c'est un problème aussi culturel
extrêmement fort qu'on n'arrive pas
d'ailleurs et moi j'attends les réponses
des politiques là-dessus j'attends un
discours cohérent non pas simplement à
quitter complètement d'accord jédir la
compétitivité le développement des
nouvelles technologies la formation et
cetera très bien il faut passer par ça
mais que fait-on de ces deux catégories
la premier point c'est sa deuxième point
si vous voulez le travail 2 pour moi qui
est très important aujourd'hui de
reconstruction l'éducation populaire
alors l'éducation populaire c'est pas
l'éducation militants pour moi ces jeux
meurent site frontier à peggy évidemment
avant la guerre de 14
parce que soit la paix l'université
populaire vous apercevez un moment
c'était le monde diplomatique faisait
beaucoup d'éducation populaire surface
et l éducation militante quand même
assez orienté à faillir les choses
l'esprit de l'éducation populaire monte
alors c'est pas ça dans la foulée de
l'affairé dreyfus vérité justice et paix
les deux sont liés la justice sans
vérité c'est pas possible si vous voulez
le sait c'est très important cette
exigence de vérité ça veut dire aussi
les faits mais ça veut dire aussi
revenir sur les idéaux premier
d'éducation populaire je n'en citerai
qu'un exemple
au lendemain de la guerre peuple et
culture à grenoble je reprends de en
mémoire sur mémoire ces orientations
c'était développer l'esprit critique
dans la masse de la nation au sens des
lumières qu'un recul réflexif qui passe
par des contenus structurés c'est pas
simplement de l'animation sont si ce
bien là dessus développer l'esprit que
l'été est loin de partager le patrimoine
culturel commun mais c'est d'une
exigence absolument indispensable
puisque je vous parlais des
désaffiliation c d affiliation et sont
largement culturel avec une question
tout à fait inédite des nouvelles
générations j'ai pas le temps de le paix
là dessus mais qui me semble essentielle
comment renouer le fil et ça passe par
le partage et patrimoine culturel et je
dirais un troisième point qui me semble
absolument essentiel qui faisait partie
de ces idéaux premier formé des élites
issues du peuple lors je sais que le mot
élite aujourd'hui c'est pas égalitaire
etc
j'entends le droit la réussite qui ont
été lancées par des associations en face
donc on est loin de tout ça mais pour
moi ça fait partie du travail de
reconstruction qui sera long et qui à
mon avis moi je me situe du côté de la
société
mais je pense que c'est un double
travail à la fois de reconstruction dans
la société elle même est aussi
évidemment du pays qui attend aussi des
réponses politiques voilà je m'arrête là
bien ceux et celles d'entre vous ceci on
parle français qui sont familiers de la
réflexion que nous développons de
manière presque obsessionnel dans ses
murs ont reconnu les raisons pour
lesquelles nous étions heureux
d'entendre jean pierre le goff
je voudrais insister sur un élément
qu'il a abordés moi je crois que une
déstabilisation des plus importantes
c'est là l'utilisation des mots pour
désigner le contraire de ce qu'il
signifie habituellement espèce de
subversion par les par les maux dont le
but n'est pas de désigner mais de
dissimuler et alors il ya il ya mille
exemples de cela mais le fait que nous
ne puissions plus nommer les choses
il ya une phrase célèbre qu'on prête à
camus mais qui n'est que à moitié de
canut qui est mal nommer les choses
ajoute aux malheurs du monde
elle n'est pas en vérité de camus mais
ça n'est pas grave
et donc cette cette déstabilisation qui
fait qu'on peut jamais savoir
comme vous savez le thème de mon dernier
livre c'est la vérité en politique de la
vérité en politique
l'idée que ce que vous appelez éducation
populaire que mostro je trouve ça très
important
civisme augmentation du civisme dans la
société
le fait que une démocratie s'est fait
pourquoi c'est fait pour donner aux
citoyens leur part dans la réflexion et
la décision sur le destin commun or ce
n'est pas du tout ce qu'on cherche à
faire en ne recherchant au travers de la
vie politique que le succès sondagier ou
électorale ce qu'on cherche à faire
c'est pas du tout à élever comme on
aurait dit autrefois le niveau de
conscience de la population et des
citoyens on cherche à les abuser
suffisamment efficacement pour que le
sondage montre que le score soit bon et
on a la vue mille exemples on continue à
voir ces exemples-là
le et c'est une perte de confiance
douloureuse blessantes pour les citoyens
que de se retrouver dans un monde où
devant un écran télévision où ils ont le
sentiment que tout est faux tout y
compris je suis d'assez près la ferme
tapis comme vous savez il ya une espèce
de renversement dans les contributions
sur les contributions de lecteurs sur
les sites jusqu'à l'audition de madame
lagarde tapie était un héros qui après
tout se venger de tous les deux tout les
truands officiel l'audition de madame
lagarde un peu fragilisé salle des
nouvelles d'aujourd'hui font qu' on est
passé de 7 oui message sur 10 favorable
à tapie a huit ou neuf messages de gens
qui disent on a été cocufié une fois de
plus il ya c'est une c'est le fait de ne
plus avoir confiance en rien quand
françois hollande a dit évidemment
c'était insoutenable on va revenir à 3%
cette année
quand il dit on va inverser la courbe du
chômage et jeudi 500 jeunes est comme
vous savez rien de négatif à son endroit
sauf que je regrette qu'ils fassent pas
les les les choix profond qu'il faudrait
fermer
de même que dans l'article que vous avez
écrit sur le mariage pour tous
déconsidérés de fait des centaines de
milliers de personnes qui vont dire
quelque chose qui est pour eux précieux
c'est délégitimer les changes que la
démocratie signifie le les sous-estimé
en participation je vais répéter devant
vous ce que j'ai dit à une radio qui
fois pourquoi est ce qu'on met pas une
autorité indépendante en qui on puisse
se fier pour le nombre de personnes qui
participent à une rencontre en qui on
puisse se fier les organisateurs
auraient leurs représentants les autres
hein parce qu'on ne le veut pas oui mais
mais mais mais vous vous rendez compte
que tout cela est de l'ordre de la
déréalisation du de ce qui devrait être
du réel et alors c'est une perte de
confiance extrêmement profonde
alors évidemment je vais pas dire le
contraire de vous sur le fait que le le
travail comme statut anthropologique est
évidemment quelque chose d'absolument
centrale comme beaucoup parlé de ça dans
des livres j'écris ya vingt ans
maintenant le droit au sens et il ya un
temps c'est le fait qu'on ne puisse même
plus chercher un travail
pour des millions de personnes même plus
chercher vous envoyer 200 cv est sûre
pour cent cinquante d'entre vous n'avez
pas de réponse et pour 50 d'entre vous
avez des réponses qui sont exactement
les mêmes on appuie sur un bouton elles
sortent c'est une c'est absolument viol
d'une violence insupportable et tout ça
débouche sur en effet vous dites en
attend autre chose
mais les les contrant que les
contractions de l'enfantement toutes
peuvent être un peu violente
voilà ce que je crains je ferme la
parenthèse j'ai parlé trop beaucoup
c'est à vous de parler excusez moi une
seule règle comme un jean pierre jean
pierre cette question
du morcellement spatiales et sociales
etc
je crois qu'une des causes profondes
c'est la crise de temporalité c'est
parce que je suis certain que je dis ça
c'est l'envahissement par
l'instantanéité et le présent de
l'ensemble de nos activités sociales
culturelles etc
bon alors sur le fond moi je suis assez
part je suis à ses partisans je dirais
ddd mesures assez humbles apprendre à
compter les manifestants ouais c'est
très important
jean signale une autre
j'ai été alerté par un papier du figaro
il vient de se créer une association qui
s'appelle renaissance des villages et
qui part d'un constat un croisé il ya
des élus dans la salle g j'imagine quand
même en corse on ne naît plus pour cause
d'état civil ont emmené vous savez là on
est inscrits à l'état civil
là où il ya un hôpital et une maternité
donc en cas en corse
on est dans les trois jours à à bastia
ajaccio ou à porto vecchio pointe à la
ligue il reste il reste quand même 360
communes qui ne voient plus de
naissances l'oreiller des choses très
simples à faire mettons l'état civil
dans les communes
point à la ligne il ya 36000 communes et
j'ai pas combien de cliniques et de deux
maternités des hôpitaux en france mais
ça doit pas dépasser chez pas combattu
c'est simple le point robert s'il y en a
15 cents c'est le bout du monde c'est un
ou deux mille peut-être je sais pas bon
il ya quantité de mesures de ce genre
qui ne coûtent pas un kopeck un
finalement 1 et qui serait serait je
crois pour bruit essayé à la petit pas
de doré ans très enracinée les gens
quelque part mais effectivement la
question du travail et est primordial
mon jeu je n'en dis pas plus et je suis
très d'accord sur tout
sur le travail pour moi je suis très en
colère contre les imbéciles et se
voudrait employer un mot beaucoup plus
vif qui ont supprimé les plaques
d'immatriculation dans les voitures des
connards pardon hein ça fait partie mais
vous vous rend en plus c'est évidemment
un gouvernement de droite qui a fait ça
technocrate ise en disant mais mesdames
et messieurs c'est beaucoup mieux parce
que vous aurez pas à changer de plaque
et quand vous le déménagement est bon
c'est qu'elle est l'inconvénient de
changer de plaque c'est parce que ça
coûte et vaille avec à dire la deuxième
plaque est gratuite
après je veux dire ses gammes des choses
assez simples tout bête c'est des
machines qui font les les cartes grises
un faut pas croire que bon enfin bref
tout ça ça participe de 2,2 ce mouvement
qui rend le monde
illisible vous êtes un voilà c'est un
monde qui est fait alors je vais pas
vous refaire mon skate sur essayé de
prendre contact avec orange avait qu'edf
avec gdf avec véolia tu sais pas quoi
essayé essayé vraiment et vous êtes tous
bac + 28 1
mais essayez vous allez voir bon j'ai
fini c'est à vous la parole une seule
règle alternance masculin-féminin faut
bien sacrifier au
voilà agnès a montré ses préférences
bonsoir votre intervention était
vraiment passionnante merci non vraiment
j'ai écouté avec beaucoup d'attention y
avait un terme qui me que vous n'avez
pas prononcé mais qui sous-tendait je
pense un peu votre intervention et qui
alors vous dites vous vous n'êtes pas
dans le politique nous autour de la
salle on est un certain nombre à
s'engager en politique
moi le sens que je donne à mon
engagement c'est comment mieux
promouvoir le vivre ensemble et je pense
que c'est quelque chose qu'on partage
pour un certain nombre et donc vous avez
mentionné les questions de déculturation
vous avez évoqué la nostalgie en disant
si quand on a moins d'avenir et bien on
regarde plus le passé vous avez
mentionné la suractivité des fêtes etc
dans les villages mais qui ne résout qui
ne résolvait finalement pas
palais des problèmes que vous
mentionniez donc ma question c'est vous
avec votre regard donc non politisée et
avec expertise que vous avez enfin en
tout cas tel que vous l'avez dit qu'elle
serait un peu les pistes où les idées
que vous avez à nous communiquer sur la
question de comment on peut favoriser le
vivre ensemble en dépit de toutes les
problèmes que vous avez évoquées au
cours de votre intervention
quel est votre prénom alice la lys
méfiez-vous toujours des gens qui vous
disent moi je ne fais pas de politique
oui rapidement j'ai pas de solution
clé-en-main simplement par exemple si je
prends la question du travail et des
catégories désocialisés je pense qu'il
faut réfléchir à un point
calmement qui est l'investissement
concernant les formations par rapport à
l'insertion pour des gens qui ont
d'abord un premier problème de sera
inséré dans un collectif faire un
travail utile et retrouver l'estiment de
même moi j'ai fait beaucoup de
formations qu'on peut avec des shows
leur langue dans le nord pas de calais
des anciennes ouvrières du textile
c'était mieux parce que tout d'un coup
vous avez cessé ces femmes absolument
c'était des situations dramatiques qui
reprenait un certain goût d'ailleurs on
se voyait dans la façon de s'habiller de
et puis à la fin du stage et éplorée fin
moi j'ai utilisées et qu'est ce qu'ils
allaient faire après et même raconté
qu'ils allaient faire le elle allait
tourner dans le quartier pour pas rester
chez elles devant la télé ou plus
étaient des femmes seules etc ces
programmes retravailler à l'époque et
est donc moi je pense que les ateliers
de réinsertion y compris par exemple il
ya des choses concernant le jardinage ça
peut nous paraître extrêmement limité
mais c'est très important
des gens qui d'ailleurs sont
généralement n'ont pas trahi et puis des
situations famille des annonces est
toujours regarder de près ce toujours
les deux là il ya des choses et dans la
masse d'argent
jai deja répartir il importe à mon avis
de ne pas simplement mettre tout en
disant on va les mettre en formation
parce que d'abord ce qu'ils ont besoin
c'est retrouver l'estimé d'eux mêmes et
on retrouve l'estiment de même dans une
école dans une phase et du évidemment il
ya des psychologues
moi je dis souvent les psychologues les
cellules le secours psychologiques ont
de beaux jours devant eux dans la mesure
où si vous voulez cette dimension
collective elle c'est rod je fais un
parallèle entre la montée en puissance
de la psychologie où tout est analysé en
terre de rapports interindividuels du
pervers de sa victime et c est la perte
des liens de solidarité collective
donc je pense que le premier principe
j'allais dire c'est ça pour ces gens là
le deuxième point de pis moi j'insiste
beaucoup sur la question du travail pour
ces catégories là alors il ya une
question que je suis passé spécialistes
c'est la question des bas niveaux de
qualification et s'est trouvé que dans
les trente glorieuses si vous voulez la
paix il ya eu deux catégories sociales
comme quand même été passablement la
mine et qui sait les paysans et les clés
petits commerçants mais à l'époque des
trente glorieuses avec la production de
masse fordienne était lorien vous
pouviez les absorber dans l'industrie ce
qui s'est globalement passé moi j'étais
originaire de caen j'ai vu les usines là
saviem la sidérurgie la smn la saviem
moulinex et qu'il y en a plus et fini
mais c'est catégorique étaient de très
bas niveaux de qualification qui avait
pas un haut niveau de formation était
absorbé la question qu'on n'a pas résolu
d'accord si on joue notamment et on a
raison de jouer les nouvelles
technologies la qualité dans la
compétitivité mais alors sajas j'attends
là mais je crois vous êtes plus
qualifiés que moi pour répondre à cette
question
j'attends des réponses sur ces
catégories là et puis le troisième point
évidemment c'est les niveaux
d'ingénieurs techniciens mais attention
les années 80 ont été terribles je
parlais d'un document signé par
plusieurs organisations de parents
d'élèves et au droit à la réussite pour
enfin en gros pour la réussite pour tous
et si vous n'êtes pas au top vous n'êtes
rien si c'est cette culture là qui est
développé dans la société ne nous
étonnons pas des émeutes ou des choses
comme ça et on joue sur quoi quand où
vous développer ce genre de mode vous
jouez sur leurs sentiments
vous jouez sur des passions au nom de
l'égalité mais il faut savoir qu'on
agite donc si vous voulez pour moi c'est
important deuxième point je reviens là
dessus qui est absolument essentiel je
pense qu'au salon on est dans une
période où le terreau c'est mon
sentiment a glissé quand j'entends
terreau c'est pas simplement l'école
c'est quand un enfant né dans une
famille ou dans une collectivité il
baigne dans un creuset culturel composé
de valeur de modèle d'identification et
cetera dans lequel que ça se fait pas
consciemment
or je me suis posé la question - mêmes
qui étaient soixante huitard camille
beaucoup de choses en laye carte un
badge jeunesse il n'empêche que j'avais
été à l'avant élevé dans un creuset qui
était en gros chrétiens et républicains
bon qu'est ce que ça veut dire être
adolescent dans les années 60 qu'est ce
que ça veut dire être adolescent
aujourd'hui c'est totalement différent
le creuset n'est plus du tout le même ce
fut enfin jeu ça dépend des familles
parce que là aussi c'est très éclaté il
ya des familles qui disent non on
transmet on assume la fonction de la
transmission puis à côté vous en avez
d'autres qui sont en situation d'errance
bon toute la question pour moi c'est
comment alors je parle beaucoup des
rites et à jouer mais comment non pas
pour le
le magnifier etc mais pour leur travail
et parce que j'estime qu'il ya vraiment
une déculturation avec un phénomène qui
est celui des nouvelles générations moi
je parle tsunami générationnel
quand je vois les syndicats avec qui je
travaille il n'y a pas que des syndicats
beaucoup d'associations il ya un rapport
qui déconcerte par exemple des gens qui
ont été formés sous un ancien moulin qui
était en gros les grands engagements du
passé qui on se faisait dans la durée il
y avait des familles de pensée il y
avait même des lignes et dans le syndic
un bon eh bien tout ça avec des aspects
positifs parce qu'on s'est débarrassé
aussi des engagements
enfin on a affaire à des individus tout
à fait nous je donnais qu'un exemple des
syndicalistes de me disent on a affaire
à des jeunes tout à fait inédit ils
arrivent ils viennent nous voir alors il
vient de voir la cgt ensuite ils font
toutes les bourses du travail comme ça
ils ont un problème dans l'atelier
qu'est ce que vous nous offrez bon on
prend et on choisit le mieux c'est pas
dire qu'ils prendront leur carte en
fonction de ça je dis pas qu'ils avaient
pas ça avant parce qu'il ya toujours un
port un peu instrumentalisé c'est normal
mais là on monte un peu consommateur
autre exemple dans le village cite
l'adjointe à la culture qui est une
personnalité très dynamique qui fait du
théâtre
ils arrivent les les jeunes couples avec
leurs enfants ils viennent il est bon qu
est ce que vous avez à nous offrir pour
nos enfants
le tac tac tac il y en a pas un qui veut
dire avec qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
pour donner un coup de main et vous avez
ça aussi dans les associations donc moi
je fais l'hypothèse que le fossé des
générations qui est extrêmement
important dans la période 68 je pense à
la rythmique qui parlait du fossé des
générations 70 je fais l'hypothèse d'une
bien c'est une hypothèse que le fossé
des générations aujourd'hui plus
important que celui de la génération se
sent petit et que leurs parents pourquoi
c'est très simple parce que les 68 eur
si j'ose dire enfin cette génération
dont j'ai fait partie cd héritier
rebelle mais des héritiers quand même
quand même c'est à dire qu'ils ont été
élevés dans le creuset ils ont jeté ce
qui leur donne d'ailleurs des bases pour
repartir pour au moins pour un certain
nombre d'entre eux
mais alors que les générations et là il
faudrait prendre strate par strate parce
qu'aujourd'hui à plusieurs générations
mais ont été élevés dans les ruines du
creux de l'ancien creuser qu'à un moment
donné dans les années 70 quand même a eu
des effets considérables et sur 1 sur
une france qui est pas totalement mais
quand même
même si à une révolte de ces couches
assez largement déchristianisée donc
c'est être jeune aujourd'hui n'est pas
du tout là et pour moi cette question là
je n'allais pas dire qu'elle ne m'obsède
elle est très importante et comment
renouer le fil par l'éducation populaire
par l'éducation populaire j'y aille à
l'école
dieu sait si je m'inquiète de
l'introduction de la notion de genre à
l'école je pourrais vous citer interroge
des enseignants il faut regarder les
pratiques
il faut pas simplement rappeler les
grands principes on est en train à mon
sens largement d'éduquer les enfants
dans une nouvelle construction du monde
enfin je veux dire c'est pas le modèle
libéral qui est en question c'est le
modèle plutôt je pars offert l'essentiel
de la mission française ya eu des débats
sur l'école entre condorcet et le modèle
jalleli robespierristes c'est pas le
même or à mon avis ce qui est en train
d'arriver ce modèle robespierristes un
succédané de ça disons parce que il ya
un mélange de rappel des grands
principes avec du postmoderne mal digéré
s'il est bon et on est en train de
de données pour moi c'est de donner une
nouvelle conception du monde
je me suis je m'intéresse à la
littérature enfantine g lire infantile
mais on s imagine pas gens j'en ai des
kilos il faut regarder les bd il faut
regarder les nouveaux comptes ya par
exemple un document que j'ai travaillé
qui est extraordinaire cent cinquante
mille exemplaires
une dame très bien et cetera où les
scellés nouveau conte raconté aux
enfants c'est très intéressant parce que
les comptes sont complètement retournés
c'est en gros le look a peur des moutons
et vous retournez tout comme ça et non
seulement ça on décrit des situations on
donne un compte à l'irs à l'enfant
comment raconter à mon enfant que je
suis au chômage ont qui compte
comment raconter lui dire que je suis
homosexuel bon et vous avez aussi n'ont
pas l'écologie que je respecte beaucoup
mais ce que j'appelle la petite musique
qui peut l'accompagner et cette petite
musique qui peut l'accompagner elle
consiste à dire et à répéter à haute
dose excusez moi nous sommes une espèce
parmi d'autres nous sommes une espèce
parmi d'autres c'est constant
c'est constant et comme nous sommes une
espèce parmi d'autres il faudrait quand
même dire qu'un glissement que la
conception juive et chrétienne de la
dignité première de l'homme dans la dent
lors de la création il ya quand même une
hiérarchie mais aussi du côté des
lumières où l'homme est doué de raison
ces deux éléments là sont en train de
glisser au profit ça comment on lutte
contre sa très concrètement hamon avait
en retissant au sein même de la société
un tissu est un réseau parce que ça
existe je suis allé à vos foyers ruraux
dans le vaucluse par exemple ils ont
lancé une université populaire j'avais
l'honneur de la ya des gens alors les
gens hésitent écoute mais c'est ce
travail en profondeur qu'il faut mener
et je pense que ça prendra du temps
parce que en trente ans le terrain a
quand même était considérablement
bousculé beaucoup plus qu'on ne le croit
et qu'on on a du mal à le voir
donc voilà ces deux axes mois
je contemple le terrain
merci beaucoup font des yvelines
la chaîne de l'année masculin masculin
bonsoir
donc le travail effectivement est au
coeur de comme il est 8h30 on va en
prendre 3 encore et plie aux cintres
donc le travail est au coeur de la
problématique du village ma famille est
originaire d'un petit village du sud
mes grands parents parler des petits
boulots qui faisaient et qui leur
permettait de rester au village alors
ils faisaient les jardins où il faisait
les olives ramasser les olives sur un
petit peu d'huile de temps en temps ma
grand-mère faisait la cuisine également
chez des personnes n'y avait pas mal de
petits travaux et les gens vivent est ça
aujourd'hui ce qu'on voit dans ces
villages c'est des gens qui vivent
essentiellement dû beaucoup de gens qui
vivent du rsa soit des gens qui ont
effectivement beaucoup de moyens soient
des gens qui vivent du rsa qui ont un
logement social ou qu'on hérite et
finalement d'un bien familial donc qui
ont beaucoup moins de dépenses on voit
même sans fin on constate même de temps
en temps mais c'est pour l'anecdote des
personnes qui louent des logements
sociaux à la semaine pendant l'été à des
tarifs intéressants en défiant toute
concurrence et effectivement aujourd'hui
la question qu'on pourrait se poser et
qu'on attend aussi des politiques c'est
comment aider à reconstruire un tissu
économique adapté au village parce
qu'aujourd'hui
finalement on gagne les petits boulots
rapportait pas plus car rsa alors
pourquoi travailler alors qu'on pourra
qu'on peut avoir finalement revenu à
côté et vivre avec en plus des aides
donc comment reconstruire quelles
mesures peuvent être prises
je vais vous faire une confidence
démarche boulot il y en a encore
black aux blacks heureusement à plat
heureusement parce qu'autrement sa
souffrirait beaucoup dans les villages
et mal an les villages c'est à vous non
mais là j'ai pas la réponse et la
question notamment deux allemandes
avaient plus tard il fonde que sur la
réindustrialisation qui pour moi est
absolument un facteur essentiel le
problème là là j'attends des politiques
des réponses concrètes
ça c'est très important parce que c'est
la question de la crédibilité la
faisabilité de ces choses là pour moi
qui aie j'attends là dessus et là je
pense que là oui effectivement les
politiques ont quelque chose à dire il
ya des réponses
alors robert et moi nous avons développé
j'allais dire centralement cette
réflexion-là ya des réponses en
particulier les réponses qui vise à
intéresser le consommateur à la
production française
à l'instant où on expliquera réellement
quelqu'un qui sait expliquer qui sait
parler et pas le le pseudo
langage dissimulateur on expliquera que
chaque fois que vous achetez un produit
français yann à la moitié du prix qui
revient dans votre poche parce que c'est
quand même ça vous achetez un produit
français
les charges sociales qui ont servi à le
faire naître l rennes vous reviennent
sous forme de remboursement de feuilles
de sécu de retraite etc
c'est c'est le prix du produit français
est moitié moindre
en réalité pour le consommateur que le
prix du produit importé
je suis absolument sûr qu'on peut faire
ça dans mon village ce que vous appelez
village par village mais si vous
entendez si vous leur aviez dit avant
qu'ils étaient un village il vous aurait
arraché les yeux c'est chez nous en tout
cas je teins chef lieu c'est vrai 1
c'est pas pareil pari est donc dans mon
chef lieu à moi qui s'appelle nayana y
il ya une quincaillerie le type quand je
le vois il me dit mais j'en ai marre de
toi parce que tu as fait campagne sur
produire en france pendant six mois les
gens chaque fois qu'ils achetaient une
poêle ou une cocotte minute
il disait est ce que c'est fabriqué en
france mais c'est facile d'arriver à des
choses comme ça que ça n'a jamais été
développée donc un saint deuxièmement il
ya une chose dont j'ai pris conscience
depuis assez longtemps et que kim wan
obsède
il n'ya plus parmi les gouvernants le
moindre sens pratique
pratique au sens pratique en pratique
comment on fait ça va avec
il n'y a plus dans la population le
moindre sens arithmétique comme vous
m'avez entendu sur ce sujet dit mille
fois je vais faire bref mais il ya une
enquête qui vient de sortir cette
semaine nous sommes les plus mauvais en
opération arithmétique simple on est
incapable de eu deux tiers d'une classe
d'âge sont incapables de faire deux
têtes les opérations arithmétiques
simple est d'ailleurs un précédent
ministre de l'agriculture très brillant
très intelligent diplômés etc ne savais
pas ce que c'était un hectare et que
vous êtes venus de l'agriculture si vous
ne savez pas ce que c'est un hectare je
veux dire à l'oeil
moi je prends mes petits enfants je vais
dans un change des cobayes fait le genre
bon jeu j'avais l'autre jour un très
brillant très brillant jeune garçon de
15 ans très brillant
très brillant science très brillant
l'aide très brillant match folle et je
lui dis je fais le coup tous mes enfants
le débat alors on apprend d'une piscine
de 4 mètres de large circulaire et deux
mètres cinquante de profondeur
combien elle fait combien combien le bon
contient alors il a calculé vraiment
beaucoup avec des machins et puis il m'a
dit 84 litres on rit j'ai fait ça avec
des polytechniciens mes chers amis
eh ben je peux vous dire que les
résultats sont intéressants parce qu'ils
ont appris des formule abstraite j'avais
avec georges charpak prix nobel de
physique crée ce qu'on appelait la main
à la pâte dans les écoles la main à la
pâte c'est là jean pierre alix est là la
physique touchés combien ça baise un
litre est bon alors après on peut
calculer est-ce qu'il ya des différences
entre le décilitre et le décalitres et
conseils de décalitres dans un décilitre
et bon enfin je peux je peux continuer
comme ça bref non mais on ne peut pas si
on n'a pas l'esprit pratique arriver à
changer le monde
or ça c'est la mutation de société qu'on
a vécu c'est que les temps dans
lesquelles nous sommes ne met plus
jamais les enfants en rapport avec le
réel pratiques et les classes
supérieures de la société
encore moins que les autres celles qui
fournissent les cadres de la nation et
le fait que la que la sélection grosso
modo elle se fasse par les
responsabilités de clans au sein de
l'unef id parce que c'est ça le ps
bon eh ben ça pousse pas les stries
pratique ça pousse à l'esprit de
manoeuvre mais pas du tout à l'esprit de
responsabilité en lien avec le réel
voilà j'ai fini pour pour répondre à ma
manière la question féminin
bonsoir je vais venir notre chanson de
travail
donc tout ce qu'on avait c'était très
intéressant et en fait par rapport à
dernier auteur des premiers doigts sur
l'école comme ils ont su pris 20 suis
pas si ça a été voté ou pas finalement
mais ils veulent supprimer la formation
la formation possibilité à 14 1 14 ans
et donc ça fera pas dans le sens où il
faudrait changer les choses donc je
voulais avoir votre votre avis là-dessus
rapidement la question d'apprentissage
moi j'ai suivi d'ailleurs des
apprentissages dans les formations du
bâtiment je pense que pour une catégorie
de l'enfance est tout à fait
indispensable surtout avec le rapport au
maître d'apprentissage qui à mon avis un
rôle fondamental pour ces gosses impose
aux troubles donc moi je suis pour le
développement de l'apprentissage y
compris pour ces catégories là parce que
c'est un aspect c'est pas le seul parce
qu'il y en a même qui arrive pas dans
l'apprentissage
j'en ai suivi pas mal mais oui pour moi
c'est absolument essentiel est là dessus
il faut faire preuve de souplesse en
français par rapport aux défis qu'on a
il est énorme enfin il ya une
déstructuration ses passes ses économico
sociale c'est la déstructuration de
l'ethos de la société ce n'est pas que
deux en tout cas moi je peux vous dire
je suis à peu près le seul dans cette
salle et au delà avoir fait l'effort de
lire ce texte de loi
c'est à ce fly et c'est jargonneux
totalement vide de contenu réel les
trois mesures les plus importantes sont
trois mesures de suppression celle que
vous dites
le fait qu'il y avait auparavant d une
organisation cycle de l'école primaire
je passe elle était bonne mauvaise de
l'école primaire et du collège on le
supprime on dit pas par quoi on le
remplace alors j'ai pas lu le texte
définitivement voté j'ai eu le texte
présenté à la délibération de
l'assemblée
cette voie là c'est le la législation
sur le vide
ce sont des lois votive il ya des lois
normative et il ya des lois votive qui
sont des voeux pieux les veux qu'on
faisait autrefois de dans les hôtels aux
quatre chemins le jour de la fête dieu
c'est ça des lois votive
c'est à dire qu'ils n'expriment que par
exemple nous allons créer des parcours
artistiques à tous les niveaux et encore
ce que je dis est compréhensible le
texte n'est pas mais nous allons créer
des parcours artistique dans tous les
atouts les niveaux de formation des
élèves en soit ce qui se passera rien
n'y aura rien qui changera
sauf dans les communes riches parce que
les communes riches elles embauchent
auront b d
l'animateur qui voit là et en irak ce
d'ailleurs ce pas sûr que ce soit enfin
voilà désespérant de jargon et de
vacuité
le texte en question masculin bonsoir
messieurs
monsieur legault vous avez parlé de la
destruction des de l'ancrage de
proximité que représentait le village
est ce qu'on peut arriver à restaurer
ses liens de proximité alors on nous
demande de d'avancé sur la réforme de
l'organisation administrative de la
france et notamment de raisonner à
l'échelle de territoires de plus en plus
vaste puisque l'on parle même plus de la
région ni même du pays mais de l'europe
aujourd'hui et on nous dit que
finalement certains échelons de
l'organisation 2013 de la france ne sont
plus pertinents aujourd'hui je pense
notamment au département s quel est
votre avis sur ce sujet et est ce que
vous pensez que les taux peuvent être
compatibles
le problème si vous prenez la question
parce qu'il faut regarder la loi vous la
connaissez mieux que moi qui est en
cours là il faut regarder exactement ce
qui va être proposé
mais je peux vous dire des choses que je
connais de façon très basique c'est que
les maires ont une angoisse fold perdre
certaines de leurs prérogatives
notamment sur la question du permis de
construire alors et ça provoque une
révolte c'est tout ce que je peux vous
dire ce ça provoque une révolte à double
niveau se dire les anciens le maire dit
mais moi qu'est ce qu'être vont pouvoir
par rapport à l'intercommunalité si vous
écoutez simplement un échelon
supplémentaire
et alors est ce qu'il est élu ou pas
celui là c'est quand même une question
par rapport à l'élu de base deuxièmement
la question de l'habitat la question
d'habitat est d'autant plus sensible
qu'aujourd'hui dans nombre de villages
ou de boer c'est devenu des murs est
venue des gens des villes qui sont qui
ont quitté la ville pour habiter la
campagne et ils ont qu'une peur c'est
que précisément les font pression sur le
maire etienne le maire aussi pour ça se
construisent mais toujours dans des
limites raisonnables on construit pas
trop etc
ils sont qu'une peur c'est de voir
arriver les constructions jésus qui a
décidé de quoi et c'est donc c'est pas
facile maintenant parce que si vous
voulez le problème
pour dire les choses globalement c'est
comme les réformes
vous avez une dimension gestionnaire de
réduction des effectifs d'efficacité
mais ce qu'oublie beaucoup les
réformateurs enfin les réformateurs les
modernistes plus exactement c'est que
cette dimension gestionnaire
incontournable d'efficacité et cetera
s'inscrit toujours dans un creuset
culturel pour les gens qui sont
concernés
et comment on tient les deux bouts
comment on tient à la fois la dimension
de la rationalisation tout à fait
nécessaire avec le fait que ces traces
cette rationalisation vous tombez sur un
terreau cayla est dans une situation
d'une france qui est terriblement
angoissée capper donc comment on fait ça
c'est alors c'est très délicat parce
qu'en même temps et on est bien obligé
d'aller finalement on va rester
il ya bien une dynamique d'avenir a
recréé il ya bien des réformes à faire
mais la grande difficulté c'est
retrouver le cros il ya eu un creuset
enfin pour moi il ya eu un creuset
humanis camp de mme auger définirait
pour faire un schéma tiquement
républicain et chrétiens qui était un
espèce de faune partage s'ils voulaient
la france est un peuple de curel
beaucoup c'est un pub de frondeurs etc
mais on a traversé des épisodes un peu
de guerre civile mais malgré tout cas
fait en référence qui permettait de
faire surgir des contradictions des
disputes sur fond commun bon je vais
prendre un exemple très concret prenait
ferrat ma france
quand vous écoutez la chanson de ferrat
c'est quand même la france contre les
parachutistes dont la france de gauche
et c'est pas la même forcément mais
c'est ma france bon le problème qui est
posé aujourd'hui et que je soulève un
peu dans ce livre à travers ce
microcosme
qu'en est il du creuset culturel commun
en grande partie faut le reconstruire
c'est un peu mon sentiment
féminin et puis c'est fini à la une à la
deux
oui pour soir là je voulais juste dire
une chose c'est vous n'avez peut-être
pas tout à fait assez insister sur la
déliquescence de l'église dans chaque
village il y à un clocher encore
maintenant une église qui la plupart du
temps évident ou qui a une s une fois
toutes les huit semaines ou trois mois
et je pense que l'église représentait
quand même le centre de l'union d'un
village il y à la plupart des cafés en
plus c'était tout autour de l'église
donc voila j'aimerais savoir ce que
quelques mots non j'ai consacré deux
chapitres on en a dit rien d'ailleurs
sur les anciens et nouveaux curés si
vous voulez bon j'ai pas entrer trop
dans le détail mais il faut savoir que
dans le vaucluse
c'était vraiment coupé en deux il y
avait cet été qu'elle est à l'église et
ses côtés au bar et quelques est par
exemple je cite les choses les hommes ne
rentre pas dans l'église qu'elle n'ait
c'est très frappant c'est une vieille
tradition les femmes rentrent les
auboises dehors et c'est bon pour
prendre cette question de l'église si si
j'en parle beaucoup je suis très frappé
par une chose si vous voulez y a rien
curé formidable qui est mort là que je
raconte un peu sa vie skis et j'ai
regretté qu'il n'ait pas pu recevoir le
livre qui était quelqu'un qui était
complètement inséré dans la population
qui allait au bar des boules
alors bon et il disait alors il ya une
conception d'ailleurs de l'église qui
était très intéressante parce que en
discutant avec lui et en allant voir
d'autres curés qui arrivait de pologne
qui est envoyé par l'archevêché
d'avignon je vais vous dire pour moi
c'est pas du tout la même conception ça
ça qu existe un acteur de ce même
ensemble on se demande comment quand
vous regardez un peu les choses
à tel point que quand c'est nouveau curé
venu évangéliser la preuve la provence
saison 2 point fr s'ils voulaient se
sont heurtés à l'ancienne communauté
paroissiale à tel point qu'ils en sont
presque venus aux mains
et aujourd'hui il partie de la paroisse
va de l'autre côté assisté à la messe
parce qu'elle ne supporte pas les les
c'est curé polonais qui sont arrivés
enfin brou la jeune je détaille quelques
quelques aspects mais au-delà de ça il y
a quand je parle de de terreau qui a
glissé je vais vous donner un exemple ce
fameux curé me dire que j'ai affaire à
des choses tout à fait inédite inédite
c'est un peu comme les bricolages
nouveau en politique aussi vous avez des
discours très étonnant de juste à
position de choses qui pour des
générations entières nous paraît très
incohérent et quand vous posez la
question à un joli nez mais où est le
problème ça c'est très déconcertant
tiens là vous avez encore une exigence
de principe de cohérence vous fait
coexister des choses qui pour vous deux
pays ont été formés différemment et je
veux donner un exemple très concret il
ya beaucoup de demandes de jeunes des
jeunes demandent des rituels is marie
pomme et quand il se met avec quelques à
ce que je pourrais pas avoir une
bénédiction alors les curés sont connus
dans le coin on va plutôt chercher le
curé qui est plutôt sympathique plus tôt
claude parce que sinon il demande un
certificat fait remplir des papiers
est-ce que je compte jésus-christ par
etc vont vous avez des trucs c'est très
étonnant je les hais les documents et ce
curé qui est décédé maintenant me dit
mais j'ai des choses ils viennent un bon
moi j'accepte je redonne une bénédiction
mais alors un jour j'ai reçu un coup de
téléphone d'un jeune etc
il me dit écoute jeunes est ce que tu
pourrais pas venir nous bénir dis moi
j'ai rien contre ça oui m'enfin ça se
passe sous un chêne mais je suis quand
même pas un druide
et bon mais c'est de tenter j'ai pas dû
et alors il est allé quand même
d'ailleurs il avait beaucoup hésité il a
pris le jeune lily attend et les jeux
vous donner un deuxième exemple qui
n'est pas dans mon livre la région de
romont il se trouve que j'ai un deuil
dans ma famille récemment et je suis
allé voir je le curé et je vais raconter
ça me dit mais j'ai exactement le même
problème avec ces jeunes
ils demandent des choses alors lui est
plutôt ouvert et là l'église à réfléchir
parce que le repli communautariste
repliée sur elle même est une grande
tentation
si vous voulez c'est une tentation qui
existe aujourd'hui et avec retour
j'allais dire de choses qu'on n'aurait
jamais cru voir possible et qui ressorte
bon mais je parle avec ce curé j'étais
en la lettre ce jeudi mais alors comment
ça se passe il m'a sorti unis une image
que je trouve assez extraordinaire que
je chante poids pas simplement
d'ailleurs qui à mon avis n'est pas
simplement valable pour la religion il a
dit mais j'ai le sentiment aujourd'hui
de semer sur du ciment et il ya quelques
oiseaux qui prennent des graines et j'ai
trouvé que cette image était très forte
alors il y en aura peut-être plus et
cetera mais c'est comme ça qu'il vit la
situation c'est pour sage quand je pense
de déculturation c'est très important
mais on a vu qu'à une partie de la
société
récemment un peu que l'on ait posé la
question semble qui dit non qui dit non
par rapport à moi je pense qu'on est
peut-être c'est en tout cas mon espoir à
la fin d'un cycle historique notamment
de ce que j appelle l'hégémonie d'une
forme de déstructuration les aux
gauchistes culturel j'ai pas le temps de
développer ce point il ya l'héritage
impossible de messiaen et ya un
ras-le-bol d'une grande partie de la
france assez assez de ces transgressions
qui n'en finissent pas assez de cette
fuite en avant moderniste y compris dans
les moeurs et je pense qu'il ya une
hégémonie qui à mon avis je pas pendre
qui est arrivé à un moment donné au
moment où la gauche était en morceaux du
point de sa doctrine à récupérer
l'héritage impossible de mai 68 comme
substitut ça se situe autour des années
80 à ce moment là et donc
elle a joué là dessus les l'a voulu être
à l'avant garde et une partie de la
société avec des relais est extrêmement
important d'un certain nombre de grands
médias d'une forme d'hégémonie
c'était gémonies aujourd'hui il ya une
brèche s'est ouverte alors on sait très
bien qu'on peut la droite ou l'extrême
droite peut récupérer s'engouffre dans
la brèche
mais on aurait qu on aurait tort de dire
que c'est parce que c'est pas parce que
l'extrême droite où la droite s'y
engouffre que c'est c'est l'équivalent
ça a pas du tout et là je trouve que la
gauche n'a rien qu'on fait à mon sens
n'a pas compris grand chose à ce qui
s'est passé parce que salah déconcerte
elle est un peu le propriétaire du
mouvement social c'est plus que la gay
pride
mais quand un ministre en tête de la gay
pride j'ai beau c'était était
propriétaire du mouvement social arrive
quelque chose qu'elle ne reconnaît
qu'elle ne reconnaît pas c'est à la
déconcerte et à ce moment là on ressort
les vieux schémas et on parce que c'est
quelque chose qui est on sait pas quoi
en faire de ça alors je ne veux pas
surestimer ce mouvement parce que ça
peut déboucher sur tout un peu n'importe
quoi il ya beaucoup de cas où il ya
beaucoup de choses et l'extrême droite a
et on le voit bien
et ce recompte elle se recompose le toit
noir parce que on a on est en tête les
images des années 30
oui mais attention les strings russes
récentes droite comme istres et nantes
devient très postmoderne moi j'ai
commencé à étudier les textes c'est très
étonnant ce qu'il soit content c'est
très étonnant le nouveau composite de
l'extrême droite
exactement et quand vous reprenez les
anciens schémas attention il faut aussi
travailler plus il ya du neuf
y compris de ce côté là donc il faut
regarder ça voilà pour la dimension si
vous voulez de la de l'église car mon
avis et est un problème avec une autre
question évidemment qu'est la question
de la place de l'islam qu'on doit
pouvoir aborder tout à fait librement
dans la société si on ne l'abordent pas
le refoulé revient par la fenêtre et
quand il revient
il revient sous forme extrémistes il y à
un angle de libéralisme moi c'est ça qui
m'a beaucoup déçu si vous voulez au sein
de la gauche de libéralisme
j'allais dire intellectuelle de libre
débat du fait qu' il faut librement
aborder les questions parce que si nous
ne les abordons pas librement et bien
d'autres vont les aborder d'une autre
façon et jeu dans cette affaire du
mariage gay j'ai été moi je vais vous
dire absolument ce sectarisme le mauvais
côté de la gauche qui arrive z pour et
deux contre et homophobe choisissez
votre camp ça fait 30 ans que ça dure
vous êtes moderne où un gars vous êtes
homophobe ou pour le mariage vous est ce
si vous êtes seul à seul il ya ce
chantage là il ya une partie de la
société qui n'en veut plus donc je crois
qu'on arrive peut-être au bout c'est du
moins mon f
mon espoir de ce cycle historique de
cette hégémonie d'une gauche qui a perdu
ses repères dans la doctrine société
dans la doctrine est en morceaux et qui
pour substituer à récupérer de l'office
culturel peu 68 eur simplement sera le
mot de la fin
1 libérez vos applaudissements 2 vous
dites qu'on a été très heureux parce que
c'était très vivant très drôle très
juste et en tout cas très en phase avec
je veux pas dire ce que nous pensons
mais ce que nous sentons et sentir c'est
presque plus important qu'avoir une
pensée articulé merci infiniment à jean
pierre le goff